calificada como una tormenta insuperable
por el centro nacional de huracanes
laura se fortalece rumbo al sur de eeuu
donde los vientos los nubarrones y la
desordenada marea anuncian su llegada
las autoridades prevén que toque tierra
entre el parque estatal sam prime de
texas y la ciudad de inttra costera en
luisiana además se proyecta que los
próximos días recorran su trayecto desde
arkansas hasta virginia esta tormenta va
a ser muy muy seria así que le estoy
pidiendo a la gente que presta atención
a este huracán que evite el peligro si
hay una orden de evacuación ya sea
obligatoria o voluntaria nuestro estado
no ha visto una marejada ciclónica como
esta en décadas
ya que el centro nacional de huracanes
también proyectó que el poderoso huracán
podría penetrar hasta 48 kilómetros
tierra adentro y elevaría los niveles de
agua hasta seis metros en luisiana a
unas 420.000 personas en texas y a otras
200.000 en luisiana se les ordenó
evacuar obligatoriamente y vamos a
tratar de aguantar la tormenta en casa
pero va a ser muy muy violenta las
autoridades también pusieron en marcha
planes para ayudar
más vulnerables vamos recogiendo a
personas que no tienen transporte los
traemos aquí los registramos y luego los
subimos a los autobuses para llevarlos a
un lugar seguro
las agencias estatales de manejo de
emergencias aseguraron que se están
levantando campamentos temporales fuera
de las zonas de impacto para los
residentes evacuados